T in this area started around
1924. in Kenya as a whole we cultivate
maybe roughly about 160
000 hectares of tea which produces I
would say about
350 metric tons a year that's why we
were one of the largest tea producers
globally
second only to China Kenya is a major
tea producer where it's a vital and
lucrative business tea accounts for two
percent of Kenya's agricultural GDP and
is one of the top foreign exchange
earners at 23 percent
about 5 million people directly and
indirectly are supported by the crop in
Kenya and for about 650 000 people it's
the backbone of their livelihoods but
the country's dependence on key foreign
exports hasn't always translated into
increased benefits for small holder tea
Farmers which make up the bulk of
producers most of the tea in Kenya is
with smallholder Farmers to have a
factory we require a lot of tea so for
the smallholders who have small little
ancestral pieces of property need to
take the tea somewhere to be processed
the small scale farmers are about a
hundred thousand hectares of that and
they produce about 60 percent of all the
tea production the rest of 40 is held in
larger Farms which are owned now by the
multinationals think Unilever James
Finlay Williamson and capturati though
they make up the majority of tea grown
and exported in Kenya there's a push to
establish Kenyan tea on the global stage
as its own brand and identity what is
picked exactly how is it how does it
work you look for one which has got two
leaves and a bud like that that's what
it's picked and then it's thrown into
the basket as you see it being done
usually it's done by ladies and you can
see it's a continuous process right so
you have to continue picking a pig
because it grows and they're a large
Workforce because as you can see there's
a lot to be picked and then it's put
into the their baskets and then that is
what is weighed and that's how they're
paid for that then it's transported to
the factory and also weighed and sorted
there in different grades and then
transformed into black tea that goes
directly to the auction where it's
bought by buyers those buyers are buying
on behalf of various packaging companies
that's how they pack it into lip turns
into PG tips into all that but we have a
few local Packers also since the war in
Ukraine auction prices for tea have been
volatile and despite good weather
helping to increase higher production
export destinations saw sharp declines
former president Kenyatta emphasized the
need for Farmers to increase value
addition to 90 percent of the tea grown
instead of selling it wrong we're not
getting fat as Kenyans in this process
and we need to get value we have to
remove it from the control of a few
people all right currently like now it
used to be controlled by Unilever it was
the one which was having all these
Brands across the globe we want to be
part of this so we also want to be
producing and also ultimately packaging
our own and marketing our own team in
that way we as Kenyans become major
stakeholders in the value chain once
that happens we can ensure the growth of
tea in the future Wynonna and Joseph are
among the many farmers in litigation
against corporations like Unilever to
maintain a better position within the
supply chain everybody is fighting for
their different rights some of those in
those Farms are fighting for historical
injustices they want those Farms to be
reallocated to the local communities at
the end of the day all we're looking for
is fairness for the minorities so that
we can all participate and enjoy the
value of our Tea Plantation
[Music]